Alhamdulillah.
First we start by thanking Allah subhana
wa ta'ala
who has gathered us here today
meeting with brothers
from all over the world
and brotherhood is a blessing from the
blessings of allahel
it's something that you can't buy even
with gold and silver
and the im the bond of im is stronger
even than the bond of kinship
and these gatherings. Alhamdulillah you
see brothers from
Africa, brothers from Europe, brothers
from America, brothers from the Arab
lands, brothers from all over the world.
Many different colors, many different
cultures, many different races.
Used to say,
"When I used to see a man from the
people of from the people of Hadith,
it was as if I saw a man from among the
companions of the messenger of Allah
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam. From the
angle of implementing the Quran and
implementing the sunnah of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam we know that
the companions are the best generation
the best of mankind after the prophets
and the messengers.
Alhamdulillah you have in Medina you
have scholars
you have in the kingdom many of the
senior scholars still living. May Allah
subhana wa ta'ala preserve them and have
mercy upon those who are dead.
But I just want to talk something about
something that is very important
and it is alma mercy and compassion
between one another.
Being merciful to your brother, being
merciful to your sister, wanting good
for them because none of us are
infallible. None of us are
we all have shortcomings.
There's not one of us accept that we
have some shortcomings. But
alhamdulillah as long as an individual
like
he said inn
and from the binding affairs of the
sunnah meaning
whoever abandons one of these things is
not from the people of the sunnah
and has rejected the sunnah not believed
in the sunnah. Meaning alhamdulillah a
person is from if they have theul the
foundations of the people of the sunnah
and the jama in their in their belief
and in their methodology. But outside of
that as brothers we're going to
have shortcomings and even the
shortcomings
the believer is like a mirror to his
brother. If we see a fault we try and
correct it. You know the mirror before
you leave the home you know you look in
the mirror some people they stay too
much in the mirror you know brushing
their hair and their beard wall but if
you see any thing that is wrong anything
on your face you correct it that's the
relationship that we have with our
brothers we want our brothers to be
better and to strive in good we don't
want to see our brother end up upon
error or we be a means a suburb for our
brother to go further or end up in more
mistakes than they already have and if
we look at the Quran subhan Allah the
book of Allahel we find many examples of
the importance of mercy between
ourselves
said
Muhammad the messenger of Allah you see
them Muhammad and the messenger of Allah
and those with him you find them they
are stern as it relates to the
disbelievers
They're merciful to each other. Look at
that. Subhan Allah. Merciful to one
another. Wanting good for your brother.
Wanting good for your sister.
Compassionate.
You want your brother to be successful
like you want to be successful. You want
your brother to avoid harm like you want
to avoid harm.
The community will not be built unless
that's our relationship with one
another. The da will not spread like it
can spread if that's not the
relationship that we have with one
another. If I look at my brother and for
example allahel gave him in the Allah
gave him acceptance but I look at him
and I have jealousy I have malice and I
say I want him to fall. you're going to
see chaos in the rather no doubt like
some of the they used to say
there's not a body that is immune of
jealousy but if you find yourselfan
whispering to you a bit of jealousy you
conquer that and you mention your
brother in good and you make dua for
your brother why because the goal is for
the truth to be spread it doesn't matter
who spreads it whether it's through you
or somebody else that's a sign of
[snorts] that you want the truth to be
made apparent and paramount whether it's
you or whether it's someone else. So
allahel said
you find them the believers they are
merciful to one another you find them
bowing prostrating
meaning the community is built around
the massid alhamdulillah in the Muslim
lands mashallah it's a Muslim country
you go out the house mashallah you go to
the doctor Muslim you go to the store
Muslim in the west it's not like that
where we live you know the masid in
reality is probably one of the only
places where you're going to be reminded
about Allah outside of your house, the
house, the Muslim household and outside
of your brothers or your sisters. You
find them bowing in the salah,
prostrating in the salah, building the
community around the masid. The prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam when he
arrived in Medina Midbah after midbah
the masid and then even with the masid
and he built what his the house of the
prophetat wasam the dwelling places for
himself and his family the communities
built around the masid
and the and Muhammad the messenger of
Allah those with him yes they are
searching for what the pleasure of Allah
they're searching for at the blessings
of allahel
they're not worried about the people
lookas
sincerity
they're looking for the reward from
Allah alone not people people may
mention you in good tomorrow and then
they criticize you without any reason on
another occasion no they look for the
reward from Allah alone so these
individuals they have they have
sincerity
likewise
It was by the mercy of Allah that you
were gentle to them. Allah is really
addressing the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam. It was by the mercy of Allah
that you were gentle to them. Meaning
the Sahabah. Look at the prophetatam.
Look at the relationship that he had
with the companions. Look at the
compassion and the rah that he had. Look
at how his interactions was with them to
the extent that even some of them if
they were missing he would ask about
them. And he's is the best of mankind.
Say you dwell Adam, the best of the
prophets and the messengers. And if one
of his companions would be missing, he
would ask, "Where did Abuur go? Where's
so and so
concern?
If it was not for the mercy of Allah
that [clears throat] you were gentle to
them, they would have run away from
you." Why? Because if you're always
harsh with your brothers, let's not
misunderstand it. As they mentioned, the
origin is,
you know, gentleness when it's present.
It will beautify something. It's absent.
It would disfigure it. The is gentleness
and kindness. But there is a place for
being stern when it's needed. But Allah
is really addressing the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam mentioned
that if you are harsh to them, they
would have flee from you. So when
dealing with our brothers,
give gifts to one another so you love
one another. There's going to be
challenges in our in communities.
There's going to be even maybe battles
between truth and falsehood and your
brother inshallah is going to be the one
standing by your side.
The believer to a believer is like a
building part of it supports the other.
The believer is strong with his brother.
If your brother remembers this
individual, he was harsh, used to insult
me, used to do ka, he abandoned me and
so on and so forth. When it's time to
stand next to you now and you turn
around and he's not there,
merciful to one another. Your brother
makes a mistake in give him advice. Now
see
you give advice to the one that you you
want good for the one you're advising.
The prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said
those who show mercy to the peopleman
the most merciful will have mercy upon
them.
There are so many proofs from the Quran
and the Sunnah that a person you reap
what you sow. The recompense is based
upon the actions. Meaning how your
behavior, your actions, the jazz will be
in accordance to that. This is an
example from this hadith and they
mention mashallah various
highlighting this principle.
You reap what you sow.
Those who show mercy to others, the most
merciful will show mercy to them.
Have mercy show mercy to those who are
upon the earth and the most merciful
will have mercy upon you. Allah subhana
wa ta'ala. Mercy,
being merciful to one another. It's not
weakness. You know, some people they
walk around, they never smile. You know,
they want to show them hard. That's not
hardness. The prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam used to smile.
Courage is speaking the truth and doing
what is correct when it's needed. That's
courage.
when the time for that courage is necess
and that is from allahel that firmness
it's given by Allah subhana wa ta'ala at
a time when it's needed it's not if you
look at
when they used to drag him through the
streets of Makkah on the burning sand
and he would say Allah is one Allah is
one that be from Allah just the human
body alone would not be able to tolerate
that type of punishment and torment
imagine being the baking son here in
Mecca and they put him out in steel
armor and they're baking him in the sun
and he's saying
that is from Allahel alone that is from
Allah.
So it's important as it relates to
ourselves,
as it relates to our communities, as it
relates to the dawa, having mercy upon
one another, being merciful to one
another, being brothers to one another.
Be servants of Allah and be brothers.
Be servants of Allah and be brothers to
one another.
And alhamdulillah if this is actualized
you'll see mashallah the da is spreading
to the east and to the west all over the
worldham as I said look at the different
colors the different faces here alone
and every country mashallah you hear
about and sunnah spreading but it's
important that these things are present
inshallah for it to continue to grow
even on the internet be we don't have to
talk about every naz
be merciful also
Be merciful to your own soul. If you see
the scholars, they haven't addressed
something, it's not obligatory upon me
to speak about it before them. If you
see
they haven't spoken about something,
it's not obligatory upon me to speak
about it. If used to say it,
these times busy the people with
knowledge, spread knowledge. Stay away
from the mahat, stay away from the
fitten.
We don't want to be a reason for the
dawa to be portrayed in an an ugly
fashion. And the
the waiting to say look at these people
look how they conduct themselves. Look
how they
so
and we do not send you Muhammad except
there's a mercy to the people
being merciful
compassionate
in our dealings even with bahim animals.
So what about our brothers?
Even with animals having rahma. So what
about your brother? You want to see your
brother inshallah in Jenna. May Allah
grant us all paradise and protect us
from hell. But we should want to see all
of our brothers in Jenna.
Our Lord forgive us and our brothers who
preceded us in faith, compassion, mercy.
We don't want to lose anyone on the way.
But at the same time that doesn't mean
you remain silent about errors. No, if
somebody makes a mistake, alhamdulillah,
you advise them in the best way because
you want to bring them back. If they
continue, it depends on the level of the
and every malar is dealt with you know
appropriately. But we don't want to lose
anyone.
So you guys mashallah especially and the
students in Medina you have around you
the lessons of the scholars you have
mashallah your communities are waiting
for you. the brothers who are visiting
here that came on Omrah everyone has a
role I was telling
the brothers as well that
even in just for America for example
there are some places maybe four mass
and we don't have a student of knowledge
for that community imagine a community
and there's four mass and there's no in
in that city
there's a role and a responsibility for
the
When you go back to your cities or your
countries to benefit the people.
Likewise, the brothers who are here on
Alhamdulillah, everyone has a role.
When we go back to our families, when we
go back to our communities, how can we
aid the community? How can we sacrifice?
Look, Sahabah, look how they sacrificed.
They left their loved ones in Makkah.
You know, the muajirun, they came to
Medina. The Ansar welcomed them in
Medina. I was saying to the brothers,
you know, we came from Kuwait,
mashallah, with the seminar that we had
in Kuwait and we came from Kuwait to
Riad and we had like a 7h hour layover
and then to Medina and even myself, you
know, it was a bit tiring, but then I
had to give myself a prep talk saying,
"Subhan Allah, we're moaning about a
7-hour layover. Imagine the prophetatam
and the Sahabah, the hijra that they had
to make from Makkah to Medina. We
complain a lot and we've done so little.
Look what the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam did. Look what the Sahabah did.
But look how Allah blessed them and what
they achieved.
Allah that famous statement the latter
part of the um will not be rectified
except with that which rectified the
first part. We have to have the same
same belief. We have to have the same
worship.
We have to have the same dealings.
Likewise we have to have sacrifice.
You could have the truth but if you
don't sacrifice to spread it then you
want it to be limited and restricted to
a given amount of people. So that
sacrifice it takes effort, takes time,
it takes.
So that's what I wanted to share with
the brothers. Being compassionate to one
another, being merciful to your brother,
wanting good for your brother, helping
your brother, assisting your brother.
Allah will aid the servant as much as
the servant aids their brother. We all
want the aid of Allahel, but we have to
take the we have to take the legislative
means. One of them means you aid your
brother, Allah will aid you.
You aid them. For example, the ones the
brothers in America, we have students of
knowledge. Maybe they don't have a lot
of money because they're struggling.
Helping them make sure that they
complete their studies. They're not
worrying about where am I going to, you
know, pay my bills or how am I going to
support my wife and my children. The
they shouldn't have these type of
worries in this day and age with the
amount of massid and marakis that we
have. Remember at the time of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam the
individual there were two brothers one
of them used to work the other brother
used to seek knowledge. The brother that
used to work he went to the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam and
complained and the prophet said
maybe your sustenance is coming because
of him meaning you supporting your
brother is a means for Allahel providing
you with your risk. So even the brothers
back home in America or in Europe or
wherever they are supporting the
making sure that they have what they
need you know not that obviously I'm not
saying that they live a luxurious
lifestyle I tell you the truth hardship
is good
you know a bit of hardship is good when
we were in Yemen
there was no hot water there was no
electricity you came out your house no
iron for the
but they were wahs.
Money was very scarce because it
prepares you for later on. You know what
it's not about luxuries. If Allah
blesses you with a lot, alhamdulillah.
If Allah blesses you with little,
alhamdulillah. But even those
difficulties, they're good. Why? Because
when you go back and you start giving
dawa, nobody can come and buy you out.
You wasn't looking for luxury.
Look how many students went back to the
west and they sold out. joining y
thewanis joining the joining the suris
we have an individual before he left to
go and study in he was on the sunnah he
came back he's with he's with the sufis
he's a sufi he was better before he went
to the university [snorts] why because
they're looking for luxury they're
looking for paychecks that's why that
difficulty when you seek knowledge don't
look at look at it you appreciate it
when you look back you look at the
colors the they have
the houses that they have. There's
nothing wrong with if you have a
comfortable home. But again, living
within your means.
So everyone has a role,
everyone's sacrifice, everyone's
assistance is important. Whether for
example the individual is cleaning the
masid, whether the individual is making
the adan, leading the salah, giving the
lesson, driving people to the lessons,
supporting the the masid as it relates
to theat, the bills of the masid. Every
single person has a role.
And again, that role, it will not be
able to be fulfilled correctly unless we
have the correct relationships with one
another. And may Allah subhana wa ta'ala
protect us all from the whisperings of
the shaitan. Remember the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam said the
shaitan has given up hope the hadith and
muslim are being worshiped in the
Arabian peninsula but he s he's happy
with he wants to cause division between
them
division planting seeds bit by bit
may allahel protect us from the
whisperings of the shaitan and from the
plots of the shaitan. Alhamdulillah.
That's what I wanted. Mashallah.